الكره الافريقيه شاهده على صراع النفوذ
بين القاعده وداعش وارض خصبه للمصالح
مخططات التمدد للتنظيمين تعمل باساس عمليه
واحد لكن باسباب مختلفه
داعش لديه خطه للتمدد من الجنوب الافريقي
في موزمبيق وفي منطقه الوسط الكونغو
اوغندا كما لديه خطه لدمج كل هذا بمناطقه
في الغرب التي تتنافس فيها معه جماعه بوك
حرام الارهابيه اما القاعده فتريد الحفاظ
على نفوذها في منطقه الساحل والصحراء
تحديدا المنطقه النصف دائريه من حدود
بوركينا الى النيجر وخط ليبيا الزواج ما
يمكنها من تطبيق طرق التاريخ
بين تنظيمين كانت مالي خاصه ولايه ميناء
الشماليه
هدفا استراتيجيا ومركزا لتاسيس حلم
اماراته في قلب افريقيا كما ان لداعش وجود
قويا وفعلا في منطقه الحدود الثلاثه بين
الزواج
اما القاعده فاهم تاشيره على الشريط
الحدودي مع موريتانيا ومنطقه ماسينا
تستهدف طرد داعش من مالي وابقاء مناطق
الشماليه البلاد تحت السيطراتها بوغيه
توسيع نفوذها في مناطق الشافعه ما يحقق
حلم تاسيس دوله لها
عوده العمليات الارهابيه لضرب افريقيا
54 عمليه حتى سبتمبر الماضي اسباب نعزومه
محللون سياسيون الى كوني دول منطقه الساحل
تشهد تحديات كبيره بعد انسحاب مالي من
مجموعه دول الساحل الخمس وسط غياب قوه
الجيش في وقت تصاعدت فيه التوتر
وجيرانها الافارقه والغرب منذ ان سمحت
حكومه مالي لمجموعه الروسيه بالانتشار على
اراضيها